JESSIE.
THAT'S "THE STORY," AND THE
IMPEACHMENT GOES ON TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THIS ELECTION IS COMING UP FAST,
FASTER THAN YOU MAY REALIZE.
HOW FAST?
SIX MONTHS FROM TOMORROW, THE
LEADERSHIP FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WILL GATHER ON
THE FLOOR OF THE BASKETBALL
ARENA IN MILWAUKEE AND FORMALLY
NOMINATE A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
AT THIS POINT AS OF RIGHT NOW
THERE'S A STRONG CHANCE THAT
NOMINEE WILL BE BERNIE SANDERS.
IF THAT HAPPENS AND SANDERS
BECOMES THE OFFICIAL LEADER OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THERE WILL
BE CHAOS.
THE PARTIES FUNDERS WILL RECOIL
IN TERROR AT WHAT'S TO COME AND
THEY WILL BE JOINED IN THAT
TERROR BY THE ESTABLISHMENT
CLASS IN NEW YORK AND
LOS ANGELES AS WELL AS THE
ENTIRE FOREIGN POLICY IN
WASHINGTON.
ALL THESE PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON
DEMANDED TO KNOW ONE THING.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
HOW DID BERNIE SANDERS BECOME
THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
HERE'S PART OF THE ANSWER.
IT ALL STARTED LAST NIGHT AT THE
DEMOCRATIC DEBATE IN THE MORNING
WHEN PRESIDENT JEFF ZUCKER
DECIDED TO DESTROY THE CAMPAIGN.
HIS LATEST CLIENT IS THE
DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT.
JUST BEFORE LAST NIGHT'S DEBATE,
CNN RAN A STORY WITHOUT ANY
PROOF AT ALL WHERE SANDERS ONCE
TOLD ELIZABETH WARREN THAT A
WOMAN COULD NOT BE PRESIDENT.
THE MESSAGE WAS UNMISTAKABLE AND
CRYSTAL-CLEAR.
HE'S A SEXIST, DON'T VOTE FOR
HIM.
CNN RELENTLESSLY HYPES THE
ALLEGATIONS ON AIR AND THEN ONCE
AGAIN DURING THE DEBATE.
WATCH HOW HIS HAND SELECTED
MODERATOR FRAMES THE STORY.
>> SENATOR SANDERS, I DO WANT TO
BE CLEAR HERE, YOU ARE SAYING
THAT YOU NEVER TOLD
SENATOR WARREN THAT A WOMAN
COULD NOT WIN THE ELECTION?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> SENATOR WARREN, WHAT DID YOU
THINK WHEN SENATOR SANDERS TOLD
YOU THAT A WOMAN COULD NOT WIN
THE ELECTION?
>> I DISAGREED.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK WHEN
SENATOR SANDERS TOLD YOU THEY
COULD NOT WIN THE ELECTION?
SUDDENLY, IN DEPARTMENTS AROUND
THE BROOKLYN AREA, LEGIONS OF
BROOKLYN SUPPORTERS UNDERSTOOD
VOTE FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME
WHEN DONALD TRUMP IS ALWAYS
ATTACKING CNN.
WHY?
BECAUSE CNN DESERVES IT.
THOUSANDS OF THEM REACH FOR THE
CREDIT CARDS AND RESPONSE.
BY THIS MORNING, THICK SANDERS
CAMPAIGN WAS REPORTING ITS BEST
EVER FUND-RAISING ON THE DEBATE
DAY.
IT TURNS OUT IT'S POSSIBLE TO
LEVEL ATTACKS THAT ARE SO STUPID
AND SO UNFAIR THAT THEY WIND UP
HOPING THE PERSON YOU ARE TRYING
TO HURT.
THAT'S A LESSON CNN HAS
REPEATEDLY FAILED TO LEARN IN
THE TRUNK ERA AND THEY WERE NO
SMARTER THIS TIME.
WITHIN ZUCKER'S SMALL AIRLESS
BUBBLE EVERYTHING APPEARED TO BE
GOING UP PRECISELY TO PLAN.
>> I DIDN'T THINK HIS ANSWER
VIS-A-VIS ELIZABETH WARREN AND
WHAT HE SAID IN THAT
CONVERSATION WAS PARTICULARLY
GOOD.
>> I THINK WHAT BERNIE FORGOT
IS, THIS IS A REPORTED OUT STORY
THAT CNN WAS PART OF BREAKING,
SO TO HAVE HIM FLAT OUT SAY NO,
IT WASN'T NEARLY ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS THAT FOR THE WOMEN
WATCHING.
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE ANY WOMAN
WATCHING AND SAYING, I BELIEVE
BURNING.
I THINK PEOPLE BELIEVE ELIZABET
ELIZABETH.
>> THERE WAS A BEEN BANANA PEEL
OUT THERE FOR BERNIE TO STEP ON
AND I THINK BERNIE STEPPED ON IT
AND SLID AROUND.
SHE KNOCKED THAT MOMENT OUT OF
THE PARK.
>> Tucker: OH, CNN.
IT'S A WORLD WHERE BUFFOONISH
JOE LOCKHART WITH MUSTARD STAINS
ON HIS SHIRT IS A RENOWNED
EXPERT ON WHAT WOMEN REALLY
WANT.
BUT NO ONE IN ZUCKER LAND
THOUGHT IT WAS NECESSARY AT ALL.
IT ALMOST SEEMED PERSONAL AND IN
SOME WAYS IT WAS PERSONAL.
JUST FOUR DAYS AGO CNN SETTLED A
LAWSUIT WITH ITS UNIONIZED
EMPLOYEES FOR A RECORD
$76 MILLION.
IT WAS THE SINGLE LARGEST PAYOUT
EVER COLLECTED IN THE 84 YEAR
HISTORY OF THE NATIONAL LEAGUE
OF RELATIONS BOARD.
WHEN THAT DEAL WAS ANNOUNCED
BERNIE SANDERS ISSUED A
STATEMENT CELEBRATING THE WIN
FOR CNN'S OPPRESSED AND
MISERABLE WORKFORCE.
AND THEY ARE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO AMERICA FOR
THIS VICTORY.
THIS IS A RESULT GETTING THE
WORKERS THE JUSTICE THEY
REQUIRE.
BUT IN THE END IT DIDN'T WORK.
AND BY THE WAY, IT WON'T WORK.
AMERICANS MAY DISLIKE